[APPLAUSE]
GINA BARNETT: Thanks, Alan.
Thanks a lot.
Thanks for coming, everybody.
It's wonderful to be here.
It has been a two-year
process, and initially Alan
asked me to come.
And we got something
on the calendar,
and then because I hadn't
written a book they said,
nope, you can't come.
So I actually wrote the book so
I could come talk to you guys.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GINA BARNETT: Oh,
you're welcome.
And interestingly, I do
this communications coaching
and I have been
telling my clients
for the past several years,
you have 30 to 45 seconds
to make an impression.
And just last week
I read an article
actually analyzing TED Talks
and what made some of them
more successful than the others.
And that article said you
actually have seven seconds.
Seven seconds.
So I've either
blown it with you,
or you think I have some
credibility at this point.
It's cooked.
It's done at this point.
Anyway, I want to focus
on something today
that I think you're all
intimately involved with,
but I suspect not very aware of.
And that is this,
your body, your body
as an instrument of
communication-- highly complex,
very effective.
But if you think of
a musical instrument,
for example-- a piano or
a clarinet or a violin--
if there's a broken key or
a valve that's not working
or a string on the violin
that's not well-tuned,
it's almost impossible
to listen to the music
no matter how well
it's being played,
because our ears go
to those distractions.
You can work around it.
And a musician can certainly
work around that dent, right?
But bodies as instruments,
we take a lot of abuse
over the course of a lifetime.
And we have our own
little places of denting,
and that can really interrupt
the flow of exchange,
the connection that ensues.
And one of the things that
I tell all my clients--
and I work with very, very
interesting people everywhere--
is that I don't want
you to not be you.
You should be you, absolutely.
It's gorgeous.
Be you.
But let's find the problem,
or the interruption,
to the connection,
because often what happens
with me is I'm called in to
work with people who are highly
successful who are being groomed
for even greater success,
but HR calls or a
manager calls and says,
there's something going on
here with this individual.
And if we can unlock that and
figure out a way around it,
they can really grow.
So that's something I want
to hit off right at the top,
is that my goal is always
to have you be absolutely
authentically yourself.
The five things I'm going
to cover with you today--
the first is how you
communicate ultimately
becomes what you communicate.
How you do it.
So I'll demonstrate
that right now.
So, um, so I really want
to talk to you today about,
like, how you
communicate and how
that's sort of like
what you communicate.
Thanks.
Point made.
Or, I want to discuss
how you communicate
is what you communicate.
Right?
Just changed your blood pressure
a little bit there, right?
Tone, the instrument, defines
often what gets taken in.
So how you do it becomes
the what, because if the how
is really out of balance
with the situation,
we can't take in the what.
The second thing I
want to talk about
is the stories that
our bodies tell,
because our bodies
are influenced deeply
by their history and
where we grew up--
accidents, emotional
trauma, a lot
of things go into this
thing that is ever-changing.
It's not constant.
You are not what you
were 10 years ago.
You will not be what you are in
10 years from now in this body.
So the story that it tells is
also very interesting to me
and is very culturally
influenced as well.
I then want to focus a
little bit on the fact
that we're all communicating
all the time in multiple ways,
but are we connecting?
Connecting is kind of a mystery
and kind of fascinating,
and my personal of obsession.
What makes us connect
to each other?
How do we do that?
And what are the blocks to that?
Then I want to, for you
Googlers specifically,
want to talk about
the data mining
that our bodies do, because
they are drawing information
from ourselves constantly, all
the time, and from each other.
And how you tune into
that data and how
you make use of
that data's very,
very-- do you say
dat-ah or day-ta here?
Which is it?
Its there an either/or?
Either one?
OK, I'll switch back and forth.
And lastly, I want to talk about
embodiment itself-- what it is,
and how our bodies influence
our thinking and our emotions,
and then how our bodies
influence each other.
And I'm going to tell you
many stories, because I have
wonderful ones for my
clients, and they all sort of
embody these concepts.
So how you communicate.
I was reached out
to by an HR person.
There was a woman in a very
global corporation, very
sophisticated, very, very
smart, knew her stuff.
They wanted to bring
her into the C-suite.
And they said, you
need to meet her.
She's obviously a subject
expert, but again, something
going on.
So I met this person, who
was as they said-- smart,
really knew her stuff.
She also had a metabolism that
was like the Energizer bunny.
I mean, she was
super, super fast.
She spoke very quickly.
She was an athlete.
She ran.
She was skinny.
But she was one of these people
who never walked anywhere.
She just [WHOOSH], flew.
One of those, down the hall.
And people who knew her
well said, oh, that's her.
We know that.
She would leave
her immediate area
and people would see
her flying down the hall
and go, oh, what's the crisis?
What's going on?
Or, the other
thing they thought,
as was projected
by this body, was
that she was out of control,
which was not the case at all.
But her way of literally
moving in space and time
impacted what she communicated,
and also how she was perceived.
And you all know about this.
If I said to you, who's
the Energizer bunny
in your department?
You're laughing already, right?
So these have
become meta-messages
that are communicated
through the body.
A second client was
what I call a stomper.
Should never walked
anywhere, either.
She stomped.
Her heels hit the
floor so hard that you
could hear her coming 30, 40
seconds before she got there.
Her walk also for me became
kind of a metaphor for how
she treated herself.
She was very hard on herself.
She was very hard on her people.
And that also became sort of an
interesting way to look at it,
through both changing
the body and making
her aware of how she treated
herself and treated others.
And trust me, changing
the pace of your walk,
changing a habit that's deeply
ingrained, is very difficult.
But when it's aligned
with an aspiration,
interestingly, people do it.
And she did change her walk.
And only after she
changed her walk did
she learn that people
did hear her coming
and would buckle down
because they were so
intimidated by this sort of
marching sound that came.
So these are just
two examples of a
how that supersedes the what.
And I have another one
I want to tell you,
which I think is even
more fascinating.
This is a gentleman who
began in the mail room
at his organization.
He was there for 20 years.
He moved up through
every operational level.
He was brilliant.
He was talented.
And then they put
them into management.
And it was fascinating, because
he had these beautiful hands.
And I'll never forget, when he
would speak, he did this a lot.
All up here.
I put him on video.
He had no idea he did it.
He saw it on video.
He was like, wow.
They're not here.
And I said, are you hiding or
are you protecting yourself?
Because that was felt
the metaphor for me.
You could not see his face.
And he said, you know, I feel
insecure coming from the mail
room into management.
And you're right, busted.
I've been hiding.
So these how's really impact if
we can indeed connect or not.
And they really do
derive also, aside
from our history and our
position, from our culture.
So that's the story part that
I think is really fascinating.
I have just the
incredible luxury
of working in many different
places around the world,
and I will tell you-- and
I'm sure any of you who've
traveled-- people do not move
the same in every country.
Go to Russia, they do not walk
the way they walk in Thailand.
These are deeply
embedded stories
that we inherit, just the
way we learn language.
We learn language from
mimicry, and we learn movement
from mimicry.
And we absorb that, and
that becomes muscle memory.
The woman who was most
interesting for me
in that category
was a woman who was
an expert in Chinese
banking, which is very
different from Western banking.
Her role was to go to
treasurers of large companies
or actually heads of state
and explain the intricacies
of Chinese banking.
And she said to me, I show up
to these gigs and they say, oh,
are you the MBA intern?
And she's mid-40s
with two teenage kids.
She's like, what is going on?
I don't get it.
And meanwhile, as I'm watching
her body and her voice-- which
was very high,
had no resonance--
her head was tucked down.
Her hands were not visible.
And she presented in a body
that was not of a mature expert.
And we worked hard on that
as well to change that.
And what was fascinating to me,
she said, if I go back to China
and I move the way you're
getting me to move now,
my mother will be furious.
Because this is the language
of my body and my home.
But the other point about
that is we are plastic.
We can change.
We can adapt.
We do all the time,
and we need to.
And we need to understand
when we don't adapt.
Again, that's another
place where perhaps we're
not connecting.
Another history.
I had a client who did this
all the time-- also very
knowledgeable, knew her stuff.
Whenever she stood up to present
she did this, all the time.
No awareness she did it.
None.
No clue.
She was also six one.
So I said, so what was it,
sixth, seventh, eighth grade
when you shot up
like a beanstalk
and were taller than
everyone in your class?
She says, how did you know?
I said, because you're
trying to be short.
You're six one.
She didn't feel it.
She didn't even know
she had done it,
because that's the other
thing about repetition.
It goes into these
deep neural paths,
and we do not even notice it.
We do not even feel it.
And the final one
I'll tell you is I'm
working with a
gentleman from Pakistan.
He's been transferred
by his company
to work here in the States.
He said to me, in Pakistan,
we stand like this.
This is our go-to,
comfortable position.
It's totally fine.
I've been told, now that
I'm in the United States,
that this is defensive,
it's cut-off, it's blocked,
and I shouldn't be like this.
He said, I'm really
trying to let it go.
He says, I open my arms, and
the problem is when I do,
I lose my train of thought.
He finds that shift
so destabilizing
that he literally the brain
can't find where he is.
Because this stuff
is also a dielectric.
It's a relationship.
Body-mind, body-emotion,
movement-thought-- these things
are all deeply intertwined.
And they have implications,
because then they
impact others.
So I'm coming into a meeting,
I'm standing like this.
Even if it's just my
comfortable position
from where I came
from, you're going
to make a decision about me.
Are you not?
She already has.
Right?
I have one client
who's so interesting.
He said, it's so weird.
I have these 35 reporters,
and I love them.
We have great
relationships, he said.
But they come into my
office and they're just
flying through their stuff.
It seems like they can't get
out of there fast enough,
and I don't know if
I'm intimidating them.
I don't know what's going on.
And I said, look at your thumb.
He was doing this the entire
time we were talking, just
like that.
Super-fast.
Had no idea did it, none.
And as I said, well, yeah.
That has meaning to people.
Hurry up, I'm bored-- whatever.
So these little tiny
things read out,
and the how becomes the what.
The story impacts the
ability to connect,
which leads me to this third
component, which is connection.
So we communicate constantly in
so many complicated and subtle
ways, but do we impact somebody?
Do we connect?
When I say it's been
kind of my obsession,
I really, really mean it.
I've been curious about
this my whole life.
Why are some people
so effective?
I don't know if any of you
saw-- literally yesterday
there was an
article about Obama,
and that he's become
much more emotional,
and he's showing his feelings.
And some senator said-- I
can't remember who he was;
maybe you remember who
said it-- God, if he'd
been like this six years.
Anyway, I don't want
to get into that.
But the point is, we
are moved by emotion.
We think we're rational?
We're not.
I mean, yes, we have reason.
We can use it occasionally,
but essentially we're animals
and we are deeply
affected by feeling.
And we can make each other feel.
And so connection to me is
how do you move somebody?
How do you tickle them?
How do you move them?
How do you engage them
with heart and passion?
And part of that is
knowing a, what is
the objective of the exchange?
What is the purpose?
What's the intention
of the communication?
So many things-- I've
been to so many meetings
where it's like your 10
minutes into it and it's like,
why are we here?
And that's not an
agenda problem.
You keep nodding like you
get everything I'm saying.
I really appreciate that.
[LAUGHTER]
It's like staring in the
fridge late at night, ugh,
you know that feeling?
It's like, why?
And that loss of
intention of that lack
of clarity of intention
already impacts your ability
to connect.
So you need to have
a clear intention.
And then you have to
figure out, based on that,
what style do you want to use?
There are different
styles that we
embed and employ all the time.
We do this organically.
When you're out with a bunch
of friends at a party on Friday
night, you're going to move
and speak and use your body
completely differently than
if on Saturday morning you
go visit someone in a hospital.
You'll completely change
your way of moving.
So we do this organically.
We do this instinctively.
If you didn't know this stuff
by kindergarten or first grade,
you were pretty much
out of luck, right?
So this is a natural
human trait, but how
do you get it to mastery?
How do you know what the
intention of the meeting
is and set your
style accordingly,
and then be incredibly present?
Which is, I think, the most
critical aspect of connection,
is presence.
And that's a word that
gets bandied around a lot,
and it's also kind
of mysterious.
Some people think
it's charisma, energy,
you're born with it or not.
I totally disagree completely.
It's a trainable thing.
Presence is about aligning
the body and the voice
with the intention and the
style and the expectation,
and it's also being completely
here, right here, right now.
Hard to do.
A lot of competing agendas.
A lot of competing things
pulling on our head.
I was at a training
a little while ago,
and the chief legal officer got
up to introduce some people.
And she told this
incredible story.
She said she had called
a headhunter, because she
wanted to fill a position.
And she said, I want this person
to have this skill set legally
and this managerial
skill, and this and this,
and I want them
to have presence.
And the headhunter
said, oh, presence.
Well, that's going
to cost you more.
Right?
So it's even a
commodity at this point.
It's a skill set.
It's a commodity.
But it's about that
aligning with the now.
How do you get in the now?
And part of that,
from my perspective,
there's a wonderful term
in the theater, in improv,
called the rule of the yes.
Have any of you ever
heard this term?
Yes.
It's a beautiful
thing, isn't it?
So the rule of the
yes basically says,
whatever your colleague in
an improvisation gives you,
you have to take in and
absorb and say yes to.
So if I were to say, here
are my keys-- thank you.
She took them.
Thank you.
So if she'd said, there
are no keys there.
What?
That's the end of
the improv, right?
And so my question to everyone
is, how is life any different?
I mean, none of us
know what's going
to happen 15 minutes
or 10 minutes from now.
This is an improv.
We're on the edge of
time all the time,
and we can either say
yes to what's coming,
and that leads to
presence in my opinion,
to the being in the now
fully and completely.
Or we can, due to these
other things I've described,
unable to keep one's thinking
process together, habit,
defenses, all kinds
of things that
prevent us from being on the
edge of time, being open.
So presence, to me,
is absolutely a skill.
It's essential, and it really
enables effective, deeply
effective communication.
Where am I?
Whoo, I'm already here.
How great.
So let me tell you a
little bit about-- let
me take a sip, actually.
I'll tell you something a
little bit about my past.
I became fascinated by
this stuff as a kid,
and it's always been
fascinating to me.
Some kids it's butterflies
or it's astronomy.
For me, it was bodies.
It was people.
And I started
studying very young.
Started going to acting
school at nine every Saturday,
and I went to the same school
all the way through college.
And then through college
I continued studying,
and then at the same time
I took professional classes
in the city, graduated, got
my union card, started acting,
kept studying, kept studying,
and started teaching myself
at 28 or 29.
And so if you look
at, what is it,
Gladwell's 10,000
hours for an outlier?
I don't even know where to
start with how many hours I have
spent in a dark room watching
to see if someone's believable
or not.
And when they're not, why.
And when I first
started teaching,
I used to get sleepy sometimes.
Not all the time.
And at first I thought,
nn-nn, I'm a bad teacher.
I didn't sleep well last night.
I don't have focus muscle.
But then I began to
realize, you know what?
That's not the case.
I'm getting sleepy
when they're faking it.
I'm getting sleepy when
they're pushing, when they're
hiding, when they're indicating,
when they're not engaging me
for some reason.
And this is not a
special skill set.
I do these trainings with
groups of people a lot,
and someone will
get up to present.
And not always-- not
always-- but sometimes I
will say to the group,
did anybody's mind wander?
And a hand will come up, and at
some point a lot of people go,
[MAKES A NOISE].
And I'll go, when?
And they'll go, slide four.
Just like, [SWOOSH].
I was gone.
And the speaker will
often say at that moment,
I hate that slide.
Or, I was totally
board at that section.
I didn't want to even do it.
It's fascinating, because
we pick this stuff up.
We really do.
We're incredibly attuned,
which leads me to this antenna
that we have, which goes
back to the data part.
This antenna is amazing.
And when I said in
the beginning you
have this body that
you live with but I
don't know that you're
that aware of it,
think about your antenna and how
incredibly sophisticated it is.
And how often do
you truly use it?
Now, I know when we're on a dark
street by ourselves at night,
everybody's antenna reaches
at least 400, 500 feet ahead.
Am I safe or am I in danger?
Who's coming?
And this is hardwired.
This is old limbic
brain on the savanna.
Is this something coming to give
me something to eat or eat me?
And obviously, we
wouldn't have survived
if we didn't make that
decision, because we
would have been dinner
early on in our evolution.
So this is deep in all of us.
The question is, how much do
you really, really use it?
So in terms of connecting
with an audience,
you need to have a very
acute antenna so that you're
reading from them all the
time, being in that present
with them, moving together,
reading the micro signals
that you're getting
from an audience.
I'm getting a lot of
little nods and all kinds
of signals from you right
now, which is great.
Thank you.
Love that one.
But also, there's the
antenna for the self.
And this is what I really,
really focused on deeply
in the book.
I don't think we listen to
this thing nearly enough.
I mean, absolutely, we
listen when we're hungry.
We listen when we're tired.
We listen when we
got a headache.
When there's some gross
signal, we listen.
But the deep
listening that we need
to do on a regular basis to tune
in to the moment to the body
is a muscle, and
we need to grow it.
So for example, you're
heading into a meeting
and you stop for a second
and you notice, whoa.
My jaw is a vice.
I'm just, whoa.
And then you sit with your
sense of what's going on.
Oh, you know what?
Three days ago I had a
meeting with those guys,
and two of them really
made me feel this big.
And I'm pissed off,
and that's right here.
And I'm not going to
speak at this meeting.
I'm just going to come in and
I'm not going to say anything,
or whatever you decide to do.
Right?
There's information
all the time.
Am I excited?
Am I nervous?
Where does that go in my body?
How do I work with that?
So if you notice
that, for example,
then you have a choice.
Ah, OK, I'm still holding
on to three days ago,
and that's living in my jaw.
And I've already made
an unconscious decision
not to communicate in
this meeting-- not good.
How do I get present?
What is my goal
with this meeting?
What do I want to connect about?
How do I open this
up, and how do I
walk in and be in
today's meeting,
not carry the meeting
from three days ago here?
Does that make sense?
And it's tricky,
and it's an art,
and it's not something
that we all can't do.
We just have to do it more
than we ever realized.
And of course, one
of the challenges
is, with signals
as well and data,
is we can misread the data-- not
necessarily from ourselves all
the time, but from others.
So this one was misread
by all his people.
It was just a habit.
But people projected onto it.
I was running a program
a few years ago.
And I video people
occasionally, and my camera
broke in the middle
of this event.
And I did not realize what
I was doing with my face.
Anyway, it ended and
the presenter said,
why are you so angry at me?
She had completely
assumed I was furious
at her, because
obviously I was furious.
But I was angry at
my camera, not her.
But she didn't know that.
So that's the other thing
about how we read the data.
How do we figure out
what the truth is?
So we have to have this
incredible antenna.
We have to trust it.
But then we have to question it.
And we have to have the
vocabulary to question it.
We have to have a robust,
robust vocabulary so that we
can read the signals and
find out in the moment,
are we together on this?
And that's hard to do.
I will grant you, that is
really, really hard to do,
especially if you're feeling
somewhat threatened or uptight.
But for example,
rather than racing out
of his room when his
thumb was doing this
all the time, if somebody had
just said, is this a good time,
or do you want me to come back?
And he might have said, why?
And they'd say, well, ugh,
you're doing this thing.
And that might have
stopped this way earlier.
But it's hard, especially
in power positions
and relationships.
It's hard to do that.
It's hard to bring that
stuff up to the surface.
But when you have an openness,
when you have a curiosity, when
you allow yourself to read
these signals in the moment
and take them in
and trust-- which
leads me to another
complication,
which is trust and gut instinct.
What I did in the
book was I went
through different sectors
of the body, both literally,
physically, metaphorically,
I'd go through the head,
I'd go through the
heart, arms, and chest,
and literally how
this can affect
his thinking process, the
gut, the hips, and the legs.
And we all know
about gut instinct,
and it's an important
part of our skill set.
It's very aligned
with that antenna.
But it's tricky, because
we have what I think
are three very different ways
of assessing a situation.
First of all, we have feelings.
And feelings are
different than emotions,
and they're different than gut.
Feelings are body-related.
They are, I'm cold.
I'm hungry.
They are from the senses, and
we can recognize feelings,
obviously.
Emotions are feelings that
are aligned with emotions, as
in happiness, sadness.
And they're very
fleeting, right?
You wake up grumpy, you
don't want to go to work.
Alan sees his kid smile.
Suddenly everything's
better, right?
So these things come
and go very quickly.
But gut sticks.
It doesn't go away.
It's got a sense
about something.
And it's rooted both
to that antenna,
but it also can be connected
to a very early memory that's
lodged back here.
So for example,
you're two-years-old
and you get bitten
by big white dog.
No matter how many years
have gone by and you're 40,
you're still going to see
a big white dog coming down
the street and that limbic
brain is going to go, [SHOCK].
And your reason, your
neocortex, will say,
that was way back when.
I've seen 500 big
white dogs since then.
No problem.
And you'll move through it.
But it's there.
But on the other
hand-- this goes back
to really listening,
listening to the body.
You've got a new manager or
you have a client meeting,
and your gut says,
don't trust them.
Don't trust them.
Why?
Is it in the moment?
Is it something
that they're doing?
Or do you realize upon
reflection that night lying
in bed, oh, you know what?
His chin looks just
like this friend I
had years ago who betrayed me.
So this assignment of
meaning-- reading bodies,
listening to your own-- these
are all really, really deep
subjects that require, as I
said, an ability to tune in,
to attune.
So you want both
your instrument to be
tuned and attuned to
itself and everyone else.
Because finally, the fifth
thing I want to cover,
is embodiment, which is, we
are not alone in these bodies.
Our bodies impact each
other and ourselves.
And that's just the truth.
Now, one thing that we all
know is when you're sad,
you look said.
Right?
It just happens.
And when you're
happy, you look happy.
What actors now, and what's
increasingly becoming known,
is you can use your body
to change how you feel.
You can use your body
You can align that changed
body with a different thought
process, and you can actually
completely shift not only
how you feel, but
how you're perceived.
This is not magic.
Watch.
I'm not doing a lot, but I
don't feel very happy right now.
All I did was drop my shoulders.
Was that funny?
Did you like that?
What did I do?
I dropped my shoulders.
I didn't make eye contact.
I lowered my volume.
And I actually
began in that moment
to feel a little bit sad.
So it's a dynamic.
The body impacts
the self as much
as the self and the
emotions impact the body,
and it impacts other bodies,
as I demonstrated earlier
when I yelled at you,
or with his thumb.
I want to read you this
absolutely gorgeous quote.
This is by a guy named
Guy Claxton, who's
a cognitive scientist.
I love this quote.
"Through the body,
I am deeply
ecological, profoundly
and ceaselessly in conversation
with the physical and social
milieu in which I am
embedded, and from which
I am continually emerging."
So there's that other piece.
We're not static here.
This is a process.
And it's changing.
This is my favorite.
"Like the wave, I am made up.
I am concocted by
the world around me.
Like a mobile phone, I may
look like a lump of stuff,
but I am actually
acquiver with information,
whether or not I'm checking
myself for messages."
And then he says, so says
the science of embodiment.
And that checking
oneself for messages
is something we can all do.
You can all do it.
It's not hard.
It's a matter of just tuning
in and making the choice
to be in the present
with your body,
interpreting the messages
your body is sending,
asking yourself if
they're true or if there's
some kind of leftover stuff,
having a clear intention so
that you go into a meeting
or any conversation
with an objective so that
you can hopefully connect,
understanding the story
that your body is indeed
telling so that it tells a
story you want it to tell.
So if you go back home
after you've changed,
you can still talk to your
mother and not get yelled at.
And ultimately, so
that your how and your
what are not dissonant, going
back to the musical analogy--
are not dissonant, but are
in tune with each other.
And that's my obsession.
That's what I think we should
all actually aim towards.
This is not something left
just for gurus and masters.
Anybody can do this.
The book itself is
called "Play the Part",
Because I don't
think we play enough.
Maybe at Google.
I just saw your ping pong
tables as I was walking here,
so I know you guys play.
So that's good,
because many places
I work there is just no play.
And it just breaks my heart,
because we need to play.
And what I want in the book
for people to do and hopefully
experience is how to engage with
your body in a very different
way than we typically do,
because what we all tend to do
is move in the same routine
gestures over and over
and over and over
and over again,
and then become sort
of locked in by them.
And so experiencing yourself
in some sort of, I don't know,
funky way-- I don't know, I'm
having an impulse right now.
Why not?
What's the harm?
It's yours.
One of my favorite things to
do is to go to a playground
and just watch kids move.
They move without any
sense of restriction.
And they do incredible
things with their bodies.
And then we just sort of
get smaller and smaller,
and now this is what
I see everywhere.
That's really unfortunate.
Look what it does to the voice.
That whole thing is becoming
12, 14 hours in that position.
[SHIVERS] Right?
So my goal is, hopefully
I've got some thoughts
into your head that are a little
bit different than the usual.
I'll leave you with one
other image of that.
Think about getting on a
plane-- taking your body,
putting it in a
steel tube that's
going to go 38,000 feet in the
air, you never see the pilot.
If he got on that intercom
and said, uh, uh, hi, oh, hi.
Oh, I hope we get there
where we're going.
You'd be off that plane.
Pilots study this stuff.
They know that 95% of the
time, you will never see them.
They know that you have to
trust that you're putting
your life in their hands.
And they-- good afternoon,
ladies and gentlemen.
This is your pilot speaking.
They use their voice, just
their voice, to calm you down.
So voice is powerful.
This is powerful.
Thought is powerful.
We're all in this
bowl of soup together.
If you think of a pond
with a rock, the ripples,
think about all those
rocks and all those ripples
impacting each
other all the time.
To have that awareness
of that is really, as far
as I'm concerned, crucial.
Our world is getting
incredibly complex,
where colliding othernesses are
bumping up against each other
all the time.
And we need to be curious.
We need to be open.
We need to observe
bodies, see the signals
that they're sending.
Alan and I were talking at
lunch about people standing
on street corners
or in the elevator
like this, clueless that people
have to get out of that door.
Come on.
It's brief.
Enjoy it.
Love it.
If any of you guys are
open, I have two exercises,
one that we can do all
together right now.
No big whoop, just
stay in your chair.
We can do that.
Yes?
Open?
And then I have another one
that's kind of wacky and fun.
If I have five game volunteers,
we'll do that one afterwards.
You can think about it
while we do the first one.
OK, so just get
comfortable for a sec.
Sit back in your seat.
Make sure your tush is
nice and back in the seat,
as opposed to forward and
you're all crunched here.
And just close your
eyes for a second.
So take just one nice breath.
And what I'd like you
to do, very simply,
is just let all the muscles in
your abdomen in your belly go.
Just let the belly
get completely soft
and open and floppy.
We all tend to hold there a lot,
which is important for posture
and standing.
But sometimes just completely
letting it flub out
is a wonderful feeling.
I'm seeing a lot of smiles
all around the room.
OK, good.
You can open your eyes.
How was that?
Anybody want to say
anything about that?
Wasn't that cool?
That's kind of
extraordinary, isn't it?
I didn't invent that.
That's from yoga, It's
called soft belly.
But it's beautiful.
It's so simple.
You can do that at
your desk, any time.
You can do a before
challenging meeting.
It can just open your
heart a little bit.
Thoughts, questions, anything?
I worked with
actors for so long.
I taught acting
for over 20 years,
and worked with all
professional actors, actually.
And I loved it.
But I'm one of these people
I have about a 10-year cycle.
I get bored.
And I got bored.
What can I say?
But on a deeper
level, I really feel
that the tools and the
techniques that actors use
should be available to everyone.
They're incredible,
and they are about
moving people and engaging
people and persuading people.
Why do we go to the theater?
We go to see ourselves up there
and be moved and be affected.
So I really, for
many years, even
while I was teaching
acting, was thinking a lot
about how can I bring this to
non-actors so that other people
can be affected?
And we're all in
roles all the time.
We're playing different roles.
We shift our styles all
the time accordingly,
and it's really nice
to have an ability
to check in with this
instrument and see
if it's in tune with
this particular role,
this particular engagement.
How do I have to shift my style?
Really important.
When I work, for
example, in Russia,
there's a lot of
pushback in Russia
and I have to be
really like this,
like that, because they
won't take me seriously
unless I'm really like that.
And yet when I've
worked in Thailand,
it's a very different culture.
I change my voice.
I change my walk, if
I'm going to connect.
And that's not
being inauthentic.
It's knowing that
we are very plastic.
We can change.
And how do I get to you and you?
Right?
And that's something that
is available to all of us.
And as I said earlier,
we do instinctively.
But to have some mastery
over it, I think,
is really critical, especially
as the world gets so,
so, so complex
and we are meeting
so many people from everywhere.
So what I love about this
book, the book has over 100
"Try This."
And they are everything,
from ways to move,
ways to use the body,
ways to affect posture,
ways to impact your face.
So I go through the
body sector by sector,
so in addition to discussing the
implications of various things,
there's an index which says,
this is for confidence.
This is for preparation.
So there's 100 ways that
you can practice and engage
with yourself differently
that I think are incredibly--
and that's also why I wrote it.
I wanted to get this
information out.
And by the way, if any of
you-- any of you-- have kids,
I have no problem with
competitive sports
and all of that.
It's fantastic.
You learn so much from that.
Put them in an acting class.
Nine years old?
Put them in acting
class, even if they have
no aspirations to be an actor.
They will learn to listen.
They will learn to
play differently.
They will learn to collaborate.
They'll use their imagination.
They'll learn to fail, and
they'll learn to get back up.
I can't tell you what you can
learn in that environment.
And I think there's a reason
why many schools have a class
play, because there's
so much that is
learned in that environment.
So yes, there's
many, many things,
so you have to go buy the book.
Very simple.
Part of the challenge
is to-- I mean, even
to define authenticity.
As in, we can smell
it when somebody's
a phony, in general,
unless they're
super, super good at it.
Unless they're a sociopath.
Those are hard to
smell, and even police
have said it's hard to smell
out a sociopath because they're
so good.
But most of us have a sense that
when someone is really being
truthful and being authentic,
that that inner part
of the head going, oh,
I've got to do this,
I've got to do that,
how can I do this,
dat-dat-dit-dat-dat-dat,
back and forth.
And then you're not
in the moment, right?
Part of it has to
do with encourage.
Part of it has to be really
listening to what's going on.
You don't want to be a phony.
You don't want to suddenly
stand there, oh, I'm
going to be like this at this
meeting, and that's the style.
No, that's-- I was going to say
another word, but I held back.
[LAUGHTER]
Somebody hired me recently
and said, be prepared.
She drops the f-bomb.
It's almost impossible
for her not to.
I have a number of
responses to that.
One is, if you know what
your intention is-- again,
if you know what you want--
what do I want right now?
So you're in a meeting.
What do I want?
I want this person to trust me.
That's what I want.
If she trusts me, then
we'll do business together.
If she doesn't trust me, we
won't do business together.
How do you get
somebody to trust you?
You have to listen to them.
When you're stuck in
your head thinking
about how do you have to behave,
you're focused on yourself.
You're not focused on the other.
And that is one of the
great destabilizers--
how should I be, what should
I do, how should I move?
No, forget it.
Focus out.
Somebody said to
me recently, oh, I
know how to move my arms
when I'm presenting,
but when I'm in an
informal conversation,
I don't know what
to do with my arms.
I said, because when you're
informal cocktail party,
you're just thinking
about yourself
and how cool you can
be, versus who's there.
Who are you talking to?
Curiosity, to me,
is the greatest gift
we have about each other.
And if you actually take
the time to look and listen,
it will happen organically.
I believe that.
On the other hand, if
it's something more formal
where you need practice and
it's a more formal presentation,
you have to practice.
My new meme-- and
you can all tweet it.
I give you permission.
I joined Twitter a
couple weeks ago.
I've got 60 followers, OK?
Hashtag-- I can't remember--
play the part book.
Anyway, practice does
not make perfect.
Practice makes
imperfection livable.
I hate that practice
makes perfect.
Nothing's perfect.
Nothing's perfect, ever.
We mess up all the time.
It's how you roll with it.
It's how you're honest with it.
It's how you say, I don't
know what to say right now.
I have so many people
say to me in meetings,
I wanted to say something and I
got stuck in my head thinking,
oh, it's not a good idea.
Two minutes later,
somebody else said it.
Then I spent the rest of the
meeting beating myself up
because I never said it.
Right?
Because you're in your
head versus really engaged
and trusting that
you may mess up.
It's OK.
You'll be forgiven.
You've got to roll with it.
I guess it's the root
of what is correct.
I mean, if the
political correctness
is to not offend people
and to, again, connect,
then yes, sometimes we may
have to hold our tongue.
We may have to say things
slightly differently
to not offend someone,
because once they're offended,
their defenses come up.
The conversation's over.
Again, the mystery
of connection's deep.
I'm not going to say
this is easy stuff.
Personally, I think you can.
I am still myself Gina
when I go to Russia
and I change my vocal
style and delivery
than when I go to Thailand.
It's still me.
It's still my values.
It's still what I care about.
It's still the same teaching.
But I shift, because I
want to make the bond.
The bond is what
matters for me, always.
It's still me.
I throw that out to the room.
[LAUGHTER]
What do you guys
think authenticity is?
AUDIENCE: Being yourself.
GINA BARNETT: Being yourself.
AUDIENCE: Being self-aware--
GINA BARNETT: Self-aware.
AUDIENCE: --in your best self.
Being honest with yourself.
GINA BARNETT: Yeah.
When I mentioned having
tension in your jaw,
you're already at
war with yourself.
So you're going to
go into that meeting,
you're not going to really
be your authentic self
in that meeting, because
you're still angry about what
happened a few days ago.
And you're carrying that.
And again, I think
that stuff reads.
It may not read on a conscious
level for a lot of people.
They may not have the
vocabulary to say what they see.
I have the vocabulary,
because I've
spent 40 years
analyzing and looking
like a laser at this stuff.
But most people haven't,
but they feel it.
They sense something.
They'll say, you
didn't speak up.
What's up?
They can feel it.
We read each other
incredibly well.
And that sort of goes back to
that richness of vocabulary.
How do we make use
of what we read?
When do we speak up?
There's also the art of
when not to say something.
That's not being inauthentic.
That's being smart.
We can't always say
what we want to say.
Now, do we have five volunteers
who want to do something really
wacky and fun?
If we don't, that's fine.
Oh, that hand wants to go up.
I've got one.
I've got two.
Come on.
I've got three.
OK, come on over here.
And the rest of
you, why don't you
just come over here
or turn your chairs
so you can watch this exercise?
We'll pick one person.
How about the lovely
gentleman in the green shirt?
You guys back off a little bit.
I'd like you to walk
in a large circle,
just using this whole
space-- bigger circle.
Make it really big.
AUDIENCE: Around the chair?
GINA BARNETT: Yeah,
just that space there.
Nice big circle.
And one by one, I
want each of you
to fall in behind this lovely
gentlemen and copy his walk.
[LAUGHTER]
To the best of your capacity.
Don't worry about being perfect.
It's about the
spirit of the thing.
[LAUGHTER]
You can all hashtag #walkcopy.
OK, now exaggerate your
walk just a little bit.
Really make it a little
bit more over the top.
Have fun with it.
OK, now you stop
walking in the center
and everybody else keep
walking but really exaggerate
that walk.
Really.
Yeah, there we go.
There we go.
Now we've got some
walking going on.
I love it.
Yes!
OK, great.
Bravo.
Good work, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
So my quick question is,
what did that feel like?
AUDIENCE: It's awkward.
GINA BARNETT: It is awkward.
It's strange.
AUDIENCE: Forcing
your body frame.
First of all, there's the
masculine-feminine thing
and the center of gravity thing.
GINA BARNETT: Totally.
But did it bring up any
different emotion just
to walk in a completely
radically altered way?
AUDIENCE: Because
you kind of have
to try to put yourself in
the other person's shoes
to be able to echo
what they're doing.
GINA BARNETT: How
often do we do that?
How often do we put ourselves
in another person's shoes
to experience
ourselves differently,
to begin to figure out
what they're about,
what they might be feeling?
Did any of you feel different--
I know you're being watched,
but did it trigger any
emotions of any sort?
Did you feel kind of happy?
AUDIENCE: A little bit.
Dina's walk was very
normal and rational to me,
but it felt like I was
almost inside his head
when I did his walk.
I was thinking [INAUDIBLE]
the way he thought,
and perhaps trying to impress
the world in the way he would
kind of impress the world.
GINA BARNETT: Interesting,
"impress the world."
Interesting choice of words.
I had a client who used to come
in from Europe to work with me.
He was very tall, very
proper, very European.
Kind of stiff guy.
And I said, I want you
to do this exercise
when you leave my office.
It was nighttime, too.
He goes, what if
someone sees me?
I said, you're in New York.
You live in Europe.
No one knows you!
It's nighttime.
And he was so resistant.
And I said, I just think
this will be magic for you.
Just give it a shot.
Anyway, he wound up texting
me a couple weeks later,
going I've been following
little Japanese ladies home.
[LAUGHTER]
He's like, I'm having
the time of my life.
[LAUGHTER]
It's just fabulous,
just wonderful.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
So we're at one o'clock.
I think that's it for you guys.
You have lunch.
you have this hour.
Thank you so, so, so much
for listening and being here.
If you have any questions,
there's books back there.
I'm here, I think, for
a little while longer.
Yes, Alan?
ALAN: Yes.
GINA BARNETT: Unless they
kick me out of the building.
Thanks.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]